but now you share something else though
because you both had breakout roles in
one of my favorite dramas and that drama
is
mid-summer murders oh ladies and
gentlemen uh now do you remember orlando
who you played
um i know that the character was a bit
of a
lecherous young man who slept around in
the village that's right
drink water peter drink water really i
don't know the name peter just drink
water
i think it was peter drinkwater i've got
a picture i've got a picture of the test
there you are look at you yeah
pete and drink water do you remember how
you died do you remember how you died
i had potentially the worst on death
scene i think has ever been filmed
i had i got a pitchfork in the chest i
was like how does somebody die with a
[ __ ]
i really went to town on it and of
course you know having just come out of
guildhall where you only have a theater
training
everything i was doing was was was done
for the theater not for a tv camera
so i remember when i went into that
first to the audition for that actually
and they said to me um
they said so what have you been doing
and i said well i just finished training
at guildhall
and i am and i had an amazing training
and i've actually just been cast as
legless and lord of the rings and
they're like
oh well would you like to come and to
have a little go at this before you go
off to new zealand and i was like yeah
okay great
it was one of those like my my break my
cherry in terms of pop my cherry for the
for the film and tv world with peter
drinkwalker getting a
pitchfork in the chest and uh kingsley
who did you play
i i i played a two-time priest called
bartholomew hands who's having
having an affair with one of the local
women but oh god
i mean forget andrew scott there's your
original sentence oh my god
that's your hot priest yeah sleazebag
[Music]
priest
you